honestly it seems to me like it's a deep
egg that was my first impression was
that it was a deep fake uh it was the
muzzle flash
yeah
this is like a perfect magic trick shot
because you have her throw something
real into like real water then you have
the CT transition to another real thing
wait wait wait frame that I think he
made a new one this is
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react I
hope it's not too cold out there for you
guys I hope you're enjoying your
holidays all nice and cozy and thank you
for tuning in to this episode we got a
banger for you today and we have a
special thing a little bit of a divisive
shot that we'd like to revisit today
we're kicking it off with a little movie
called Donald Justice Donald
Justice
I guess we're jumping right in all right
all right so I want you guys to watch oh
do you see it wait I saw a CG dude
running in the background no no no
they're all CG dudes oh now there's some
CG butterfly man you guys are probably
looking at everything going on yeah
there's a lot going on there's a lot
going on it's a big small thing that
really stands out a little bit of
context here I want you guys to look at
the muzzle flashes and tell me if
there's something wacky okay ready for
it
you see it uh yeah was the muzzle flash
backwards yeah yeah the muscle flash was
backwards
that's a weird one that's a really
strange one that's like something you
definitely don't expect there's no way
it like slips by you well like I can see
it happening if there's like some sort
of like accidental like effect that went
into place and it just got perfectly
rotated 180 degrees Yeah so I'm just
like oh I like the look of it when you
flip it the other way real life
sometimes that muscle flashes can look
like that but I mean it's definitely
backwards if you look at more frames you
can definitely see like the stuff coming
out of the muzzle like a little shadow
of the muzzle the gun on the wrong side
of the muzzle flash it's very strange
like how do you fix it you flip it the
other way like it's this isn't really
like you can't go too deep into like the
technical aspects here because it's a
pretty simple issue but like is it an
Easter egg did somebody go like you know
I think I can slip this in and nobody's
gonna notice and now we noticed like is
that what it is it just took a few years
like I don't I don't want to [ __ ] on it
because there's nothing worth [ __ ]
on right it's like look at this actual
shot here like the shot is pretty sweet
yeah there's like a very well executed
VFX shot happening and then there's a
little flipped muzzle flash and it's one
of those beautiful Mysteries right like
the Optimus Prime low frame rates bark
in his face yeah
and it's like millions of dollars and
then like somebody's like watch this
180.
overall it's just like I feel like this
movie is a it was examples of a lot of
money and arguably a lot of talented and
like very skilled people coming together
but like it's like putting a puzzle
piece together but they're not quite the
right puzzle pieces so it's a little
weird of a gap there it's like Ugh
something's missing so that that was uh
Mr Donald Justice Donald Justice Batman
v Superman Donald justice so fun story
uh I was at a restaurant a few days ago
and this guy's like hey big fan of the
channel I'm like oh thanks you're in the
business he's like yeah working this
show called Foundation I'm oh really
like I love that she's like yeah I'm one
of the writers what dude Foundation is
great yeah what a great show amazing so
I told him I had a shot that I wanted to
show you guys okay I do it's one single
shot and it's one of the shots where it
hits and you're like that's a nice shot
are we alone
thank you
I have like the rings around this water
planet
almost hit that alien fish squid
[Music]
oh this one right I remember seeing this
and being like
that's sweet it's very satisfying I like
how they have like the fragmented canoe
you can still see all the seams and then
they'll just kind of like disappear this
is like a perfect matcha trick shot
because you have to throw something real
until like real water then you have the
CT transition to another real thing like
that water I saw the transition I saw
the transition on the water two
different water elements yeah you see
the splashes from the thing she throws
down and then as it turns into the canoe
oh yeah linear wipe between the canoe
and the spaceship canoe but it works
really well though I love how they have
like the extra little skimmed water
splash yeah like timed really really
well with it I always wonder if they
dropped the canoe there also to get that
Splash look at this Splash and they just
dropped the canoe to get that Splash and
there's something I mean probably right
I don't think it's a water I mean I'm
sure it's a little bit of water Sim at
times but I think the actual Splash from
the canoe and the splash when she throws
the canister those both strike me as
real splashes I think you're right I
think they are real splashes so they're
having to paint out the water where the
CG canoe is but they're still using
those water splash elements yeah it's
like when it expands they're hitting
some sort of transition and once it's
fully expanded you can see there's
another Splash that happens there that's
the real Splash from the canoe I think
this show is like full of these kind of
shots where they're visual effect shots
that are truly like here's a special
shot it's a magic trick versus like
here's a shot we spent a million dollars
in the background in something that
doesn't matter it's like this whole show
Just Nails those moments I'm so glad
that this show exists and there's some
sci-fi like this that's out there yeah
if you haven't seen Foundation highly
recommend it
because Addie has to know I fought for
her
all right have you guys seen the
unbearable weight of massive talent I
have not seen it this is the Nicholas
Cage movie right where he's like playing
himself well he's playing Nick Cage with
a k n i c k Nicholas Cage is he spells
his name with the c right yeah but take
a look at this tell me what you think
leave it to the professionals
local police whomever what there's
something uncanny about it and I'm
pretty sure it's the shape of his
cheekbones his face is very just like
like triangular huge cheekbones it looks
pretty dang good it's obviously a
younger Nick Cage here what movie is he
from in this alternate version of him
this version of him here is specifically
from a talk show appearance in 1990 when
he's promoting the movie Wild at Heart
that he made with David Lynch this
represents the wild Nick Cage from like
90s and they took this persona but they
took his face from 1995 to 2000 which is
when he is on all the Blockbusters
honestly it seems to me like it's a deep
fake that was my first impression was
that it was a deep fake like especially
on that one shot where he like Wiggles I
almost like feel like I'm seeing through
the Deep fake for a moment look at this
see that see that like you almost like
see a beard appear do you see that you
see his beard yeah so the question then
is who is the actor underneath the Deep
fake is it Nicholas Cage I think he's
100 Nicolas Cage you were never
me then there's
a clown man did clown makeup and the
Deep fake like this oh yeah clown make a
plus defect there's some compositing
going on because his hair comes down in
front of his face there a little bit and
you can't really just composite a deep
fake on top of hair you have to cut the
hair out and so there's probably some
blending going on into the original
Nicholas Cage forehead there but also
combined with some de-aging effects
there's someone in his reflection whoa
okay this in the car is incredible it
looks Flawless so this is done by Cosa
VFX they also did old bill from
Westworld okay yeah you know like the
jerky guy he was like half her watch
yeah he was a really good robot dance
and now details are a little slim online
I feel like they're careful not to call
the Deep pick but it's definitely AI
assisted which tells me that there's
probably deep fake elements in it but
there's a ton of compositing work and
it's really easy to take away from all
the work when you say oh we could do
some AI tools it's like saying oh we
used you know we used After Effects yeah
you know something like this you have to
morph the face shape you have to deal
with a lot of lighting look he's in his
glasses there that reflection in his
glasses you have all this hair masking
to deal with in front of the face you
have lens layers from things outside the
car going by like there's a ton of work
going on here that's not a deep fake
thing you know stuff that you just have
to have really talented artists like
adding in and blending out you know
tweaking all those elements like look at
the blend in the neck you know like the
blend of the neck is perfect yeah this
is this some of the best D aging I've
ever seen honestly right here it's so
emotive because usually when you do a
deep fake you lose a lot of expression
it's like it's like you take the Peaks
and The Valleys you just bring them in
you just have a neutral face but like
Nick Cage does not have neutral face
right Nick Cage hits big Peaks and
valleys you listen to me you're Nick
hey
like the teeth the inner like you can
see the inside of his mouth really
clearly yeah you're probably only going
to get that by actually using Nick Cage
and like pulling in the bits of his face
as needed so in that one part where Sam
saw the beard coming through they're
probably pulling in more of the
underneath face to get like the lip
wrinkles and the face Distortion and the
motion blur the other added benefit of
all this is that when you do a deep fake
onto the same person you're not that far
off on face structure the teaks in yeah
but the eyes are the correct distance
apart the face is the correct length I
was actually wondering they probably
used the real eyes the entire time yeah
it's probably just shining through and
like those lips I bet you that's like
actual neck cages lips there being cut
out from underneath yeah it's incredible
it looks really good I mean well first
off you know it's not real so instantly
your eyes are working against your brain
but even despite that it like holds up
so well we've looked at so many de-aging
shots like Irishman High Fidelity great
great still frames but in motion it
looks like you get The Uncanny effect
from that this one's really convinced
thing and they're attempting to do one
of the hardest things if not the hardest
thing to do in all of visual effects
yeah in a way like I almost feel like
this is not getting recognized enough
because the Luke Skywalker de-aging is
probably the only other thing that's
like at this level now and Cosa just
comes out and makes this and it's like
damn it's really impressive and the
movie's really good if you liked RR and
you want like just not quite as insane I
like this movie if you'd like to give us
a Christmas present consider subscribing
so a few weeks ago the Avatar trailer
came out and we were all like wow and
there's a few reasons we said wow though
because we'd heard about so much of the
development behind the movie I mean who
hasn't we've been hearing development
about it for 10 years so it's kind of a
big deal but like as of late there have
been so many great things been released
about patents for waiters water
simulation systems to the new camera
technology to underwater motion capture
there's things that seem to be pushing
visual effects beyond the limits that we
are used to so when one particular shot
came up we were all blown away and the
whole thing was that like we were
adamant boldly adamant that this shot
was 100
CGI let me see I actually wasn't here
for that react episode take a look at
this one shot and tell us whether you
think this is 100 CG or if there's
anything real in it
do those caustics on that whale yeah
okay there it is there it is the
smallest shot the reason we're
revisiting this is because we've heard
some secondhand information that this
shot possibly was done well partially
practically which is crazy considering
everything we've seen before this is
basically 100 CG but then the kicker
there was actually a small behind the
scenes clip released showing some of the
props from the film and specifically a
prop that matches this shot identically
which potentially brings this to the
side of it being partially photoreal
which is still a Preposterous notion
okay I mean like also I think it's
important to clarify this is a pretty
classic move for what it FX and what a
workshop they build all these props so
that you can actually get that real life
craftsmanship building these things so
that you can have those small variations
in all of the fine detail and then you
have the team come through and digitize
everything using it as reference and
getting it to look as realistic as
possible to the real thing but then you
get the flexibility of being able to put
it in all the shots in the whole movie
so that's a pretty normal thing it's not
like because they made it practically
therefore proves the shot was real no
that's not the same thing so like okay
then we let it go months went by then
the new trailer comes out and this shot
is slightly altered we they did it again
well okay I am 100 willing to admit I am
wrong if it is actually real but I'm not
convinced yet we don't actually have any
hard evidence let me see the new shot
Just Breathe
there's a new version of that shot
that's even wider angle this is It's a
completely different shot the big thing
with this shot is the Striking Fidelity
in which the hands and the leather and
all this stuff are interacting and
coming in and out of the water something
that has felt basically impossible until
now you know what in the court of VFX
you can't just do things on wins you
have to have some Visual Evidence all
right I got some Visual Evidence on the
left why I think this is real bubbles on
the top of the water sure you can do CG
bubbles but a lot of this is like did
they think of it right the way the
bubbles distort the light around the way
they refract the stuff underneath I
think the bubbles are an indicator that
the shot is real secondly the way the
water washes up on that bumpy pad
there's surface tension and water that
pulls it into the little cracks and
crevices between those yeah there's a
patent that allows them to specifically
do that regardless it's a very fine
detailed thing that you don't really see
in water Sims very often especially with
like the fine detail it needs to have or
something like this third the way the
water droplets congeal with their
surface tension on the leather
especially with like the little seam on
the edge of that leather strap the water
hits that and it congeals right on that
seam like right before it seem like real
water does these are very very fine
fine-tuned like physical interactions
and could you simulate in CG sure but at
a certain point the amount of detail
across the entire image gets to be what
I consider to be too much for a human
being to just have that complexity in
their mind to deal with right so if we
go to the other shot now the new shot in
the new trailer I don't see any bubbles
on the surface of the water let's look
for bubbles not froth but specifically a
bubble that sits there and refracts
stuff underneath do you see any Bubbles
at all no I do not there's not a single
bubble in the shot secondly if you look
at the water splashing onto that pad
that like straw pad again you don't have
the surface tension or the water in the
seams between yeah you do I'm looking at
it oh it's just on top it's just on top
it's just like liquid I'm looking on
this strap on the right so look at the
strap what I see is a wet map and like
water on top I don't see surface tension
these wet Maps yeah I don't see surface
tension pulling beads of water to the
edges of like the stone seams I see
wetness I see like a Shader change but I
don't see actual like water beads with
surface tension gripping to the leather
the way it would in real life I see an
incredible High Fidelity piece of CGR
right here and I could be wrong right
it's that good I could totally be wrong
having the water tension around an
actual Stitch is something that I didn't
even think about looking at in the
original shot and now that you're
pointing it out you're like okay yeah
this does give a lot more evidence to
that original shot being real I saw
another hypothesis online is that they
actually did film that shot for real in
a tank which is what they are claiming
and that's as close as the shot is it
was just made for a shot that's on
screen for maybe one or two seconds and
I think that's probably true but that
doesn't actually tell us that shot in
the final movie is practical or real
because they do this all the time I'm in
the marketing of movies where they'll
say they film something practically and
there are no visual effects here and we
see the actual physical thing on set and
whatnot and then when you see the VFX
breakdown you see like the little like
Transitions and wipes and then like real
shot and then like delete and then yeah
so it's like I guess what I'm trying to
say is that it's not unheard of for them
to be like oh yeah we shot this
practically for the movie and for that
to be a lie I'm not saying it is a lie
in this situation I'm just saying it's
not unheard of so assuming that original
shot is filmed practically I still think
there is some hybrid CG going into it
like I think they probably actually
added in the CG arms for it but if the
idea is that they're just dropping in
for the trailer they probably wouldn't
have put all that much effort into this
one super quick shot I agree I think the
original one on second viewing here we
have composited arms there's a practical
element down there the new one 100 CG
fight me
I mean hey if if that first one was
definitely real footage then I was was
wrong about my stance on it or not but
we still don't know for sure and they
probably won't actually ever say
anything because it's different in the
final movie if it's not two different
shots I think it's really worth noting
that the fact that we're all arguing
over this shot to close my hands of the
strap shows you that when we saw the
shot there's just something about the
water and the way it moved that was
beyond anything we've ever seen before
in animation even though it's such a
mundane shot it's triggering something
in our minds and perhaps that's an
indication that that first shot was real
and just slipping it in amongst all the
animations something like Whoa
that was really good exactly because
that's the same thing that happened to
us we're like all this like oh yeah this
is sweet CG and they're like hey hold on
yeah exactly exactly
it's sweet though I can't wait to see
this movie I don't care I'm not a big
Avatar fan but I'm excited to see the
movie oh I'm super excited for the movie
I'm excited for the movie too online
right now this is blowing up and the
fact that like we took a hard stance
saying that that original shot was not
real dude that's a compliment that's a
huge it is a compliment right we're
always guessing for a lot of this stuff
especially stuff where breakdowns
haven't been released yet you know the
artist's working on it are under NDA and
they can't really talk about it either
and so it's like we're always having to
do a lot of guesswork here and that's
just how it is and people will respond
well if you're having a guesswork maybe
you shouldn't be doing it well then I
don't know what to tell you I'm sorry
Merry Christmas Eve everybody thank you
for taking a moment to spend your
holidays with us hope you're having a
good one it's been a chill year a lot of
ups and downs here getting to meet Tim
Miller obviously you guys filmed a sweet
episode with him having Adam Savage that
was this year right yeah
we did the collab with him this Summer
God damn dude thanks for tuning in this
whole year thanks for allowing us to
continue doing what we do leave a
comment down below what was your
favorite video we put out this year yeah
tell us your favorite video maybe in
your favorite react episode maybe even
your favorite react moment it's a lot of
really fun videos so thanks for joining
us for all of them and I'm looking
forward to seeing uh what next year
brings